Oh yeah best friendship ever
Welcome back everyone this is my full
rick and morty season 5 episode 8 video
the welcome back bird person episode there's so
many mind blowers and big reveals about rick's
history the truth of rick's history so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes there's
a bunch of really big stuff happening this week
too and also talk about the finale because they
changed the schedule because of what they're
doing with the finale it's going to be a full
hour long i'm still doing the giveaway for rick
and morty merch all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave your favorite big reveal
or easter egg or reference from the episode on
the video careful for spoilers from the entire
episode if you haven't seen it yet i'll number
these easter eggs and moments as we go along to
stay organized starting with the episode title
ricternal friendshine of the spotless mort which
is a reference to the movie eternal sunshine of
the spotless mind during that movie jim carrey is
trying to get over a breakup with his girlfriend
kate winslet he signs up for a service that's
going to remove her from his memories literally
but while it's happening he changes his mind
deciding that he loves her and tries to save
his memory of her with the two of them running
through different memories of his trying to keep
the memory of her alive during the episode a
version of bird person attempts to destroy himself
literally blow his mind from the inside out and
as the reality of his memories start to crumble
around him his mind starts to crumble the ricks
are running around trying to save him they're like
the jim carreys running around in eternal sunshine
for bird person though the thing that makes him
change his mind and want to live to save himself
is learning that he has a secret half bird person
child with tammy that's alive in the real world
being held captive on an asteroid prison by
the remnants of the galactic federation that's
obviously something that they'll have to cover
in a future episode so i'll address that when we
get to that part of the video but that's only one
thing on a long list of big mind blowers that they
reveal about rick's history mines were being blown
metaphorically and literally during the episode
and one of the devices that they used to escape
was from the morty's mind blowers episode
but the actual episode starts with the rest of the
family going on a cruise leaving rick by himself
at the house beth kind of joking about a lot of
movies where they leave kids on by themselves
without parental supervision rick makes a pickle
rick reference claiming the minute they leave
the chance of his ego swelling out of control
him attempting another pickle rick scenario
shoots through the roof which it kind of does he
doesn't turn himself into a pickle but he does
turn himself into pure thought to enter bird
person's mind the entire episode is full of
references like this to earlier episodes as well
as revealing older events in rick's life that he
and bird person only talked about during season
1 and season 2 like the battle of blood ridge
we also get to see them forming their band flesh
curtains for the first time just the whole episode
is full of nuggets like this so he finally
brings phoenix person out of storage where he's
been since the end of season 4 with him inside the
compartment in his garage and proceeds to get into
it with the ai of his garage who offers to suck
his and their neighbor's Gene's d*cks multiple
times Gene is getting a whole lot of play this
season not only did they reference him last week
rick also ran over him with the car during episode
4 when morty's mutant sperm were killing everyone
he removes all bird person's cybernetic
enhancements so that he looks a little
bit more like himself he does have a bunch of
extra scarves from his original death and all
the surgery that the federation performed on him
the reason why the ai has the anxiety attack and
starts stalling for time is just because it
isn't able to fix bird person the way that
rick wants him to be fixed and she's afraid that
rick is going to terminate her program which is
when she starts waffling and offering to suck
him off the whole idea that she's terrified of
dying the ai is terrified of dying is also meant
to be a parallel for bird person wanting to die
then deciding that he does not want to die during
the episode they set up the whole eternal sunshine
plot by saying that bird person hid his original
mind deep inside his own memories to protect it
from the galactic federation when they turned him
into phoenix person the reason why rick doesn't
take the ai up on his suggestion to just hop to
a different timeline or different universe where
bird person is fine and steal another version of
him is because he wants to restore the version of
bird person who he grew up with his original bird
person later in the episode a younger version of
him at bloodridge also tries to float this same
idea to a younger bird person after their battle
like look nothing matters infinite realities let's
go have adventures so when rick tells his ai that
he's not going to do that it's his way of saying
that he's matured since blood rich he's admitting
to himself that some things do matter bird person
matters to him and he also kind of confesses this
to the memory of his younger self later in
the episode that they love their friend bird
person even though his younger self isn't ready to
admit that yet when he's loading up the process to
convert himself into a thought that's the pickle
rick moment of the episode you see he's got a
sentient energy based creature trapped in the wall
melting it down to power the process it's the same
creature that he's smoking at their sci-fi version
of burning man later in the episode they said at
the whole joke with the garage ai trying to
get gene's help with the batteries because
rick explains that if something does go wrong and
he dies while inside bird person's mind the ai
battery only lasts for 600 years the ai freaking
out so badly when things look like they're going
off the rails thinking that it might die that it
tries to wrangle in gene's help by offering to
suck him off and using the marvel movies there's
so many marvel references this season i've already
talked about in the previous episode videos a lot
of former rick and morty writers are now working
on new marvel movies in marvel disney plus series
like the loki show runner was a former rick and
morty writer he also wrote the doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness movie one of the other
writers who wrote the pickle rick episode which
they referenced during this episode is actually
working on the marvel disney plus she-hulk series
dan harmon himself made a joke about how marvel is
stealing a bunch of his writers but he said
it in jess like he's not upset about it the
marvel reference here though is gene is like oh
you're kind of like a version of jarvis and when
the ai says haha i wish that's just a reference
to how much rick mistreats her and abuses her
rick starting out in that giant bird skull is just
meant to be a representation of him entering bird
person's mind literally like he starts out where
the brain would be inside this skull but the
reason why it's ultra stylized is in service of
the charlie kaufman joke that they pay off later
which is actually the second charlie kaufman joke
this season they made another reference to him
during the thanksgiving turkey episode when jerry
was watching that really messed up trippy version
of a charlie kaufman wizard of oz movie he also
says with a joke about him being naked because
it's so artsy which they then pay off immediately
when his clothes disintegrate off of him
him diving into the hole is also a representation
of him traveling down into bird person's deepest
memories like he's diving into a giant ocean
of memory the egg that he crashes through into
the yoke is just a reference to bird person's
birth because he's traveling forward through
bird person's memories like each new memory that
he travels to is further forward in the timeline
this is also meant to be a reference to foreshadow
the birth of bird person's child with tammy
later in the episode all the trippy transitions
between the different memories is a thing from
eternal sunshine in that movie the memories start
to bleed together so they cut between the scenes
with really trippy transitions like this the
next memory rick goes to is a version of an
intergalactic burning man mixed with lollapalooza
they call it burning man a palooza flargabarg
this is meant to be the moment where he met bird
person for the first time because this rick has
the same clothes and almost the same haircut i'm
assuming that not a ton of time passes between
this and the events of blood ridge so we'll say
rick was already approaching his mid-30s when this
was happening because he's about 35 when blood
ridge happens he meets bird person who apparently
also loves to party they get high together bird
person explains that he's called bird person
because his culture doesn't believe in names
that's the writers joking about how in real life
they were kind of lazy when they first created the
bird person character like well he's a bird and
he's a person so we'll call him bird person his
actual first appearance was in season 1 episode
11 when he shows up at the house party saying the
beacon was activated there's a cool call back to
that during the episode when they break up at
blood ridge bird person says if you ever need me
activate the beacon so the house party was the
first time that he activated the beacon a couple
years ago dan harmon revealed that bird person
is meant to be a parody of the sorceress from
he-man and the masters of the universe because she
wears the bird costume all the time and changes
into a bird rick takes the porta potty into the
next memory of them together and it's them on
a mission with rick trying to get revenge against
the citadel of rix for the death of his wife diane
if you couldn't tell that's basically what's
happening here that's why they say killing us
won't bring her back so this is actually a really
big deal it's one of the big truth bombs that
they drop about rick's history during the episode
because remember these are bird persons memories
so you know that the events really happened
earlier this season mr nimbus confirmed that
rick's wife died a long time ago and during season
3 episode 1 he showed us a memory of the citadel
of rix murdering her in order to get rid of rick's
family so that he would be more willing to join
them but at the time rick claimed that that memory
was false or could be false so we couldn't really
trust it as fans whether or not the citadel of
ricks really were behind the death of his family
later in the episode they seemingly back this idea
up that that memory was real when they reveal that
beth has been a clone this whole time that's what
younger rick meant when he said you've been living
with a version of your dead daughter implying that
this whole memory of them dying in this explosion
was actually real this whole time that felt like
an even bigger reveal than bird person's child
during the episode but then he travels to the
next memory which is then planning the battle
a blood ridge and we meet his original crew some
of them were referenced in previous episodes like
bird person squanchy we know still wondering
where he is in present day squanchy is still
alive until confirmed otherwise this is geared
dude he's the older brother of gearhead from
previous seasons we also see a younger version of
gearhead inside the memory of gear dude's funeral
when they run him over poor old gearhead he just
can't catch a break as far as i know they don't
give names to these other three crew members here
but maybe we'll find out about them some other way
the younger 35 year old memory version of rick
discovers c137 who wins him over after revealing
that he's a memory wait a minute why was my ninth
birthday party in a pine tree it's just because
bird person wasn't there for rick's ninth birthday
party so he has no idea what happened during that
they kind of use this to set up the whole logic
for how the memories work and give you the rules
the memory versions can't use their portal guns
for instance because bird person never understood
where they were using the portals to travel to
also setting up the twists later that they can
only use technology of ricks that per person
remembers and understands you also notice this
younger version of rick is carrying around a much
more primitive version of his portal gun they both
make a joke about no one having true free will
that was actually a pretty big thing during the
loki finale the loki series was done like i said
by one of the former writers on rick and morty the
whole premise of the loki series though was that
the only person in the universe who had true free
will or the multiverse if you want to think about
it that way was a version of kang called he who
remains who was controlling the entire timeline so
we'll see if we have a similar payoff on rick and
morty with someone secretly orchestrating events
on a multiversal scale and here we go again with
all the evil morty theories then they travel
to the next memory where they finally find the
real bird person watching a memory of his from
a time earlier in his relationship with tammy
they do the same gross tammy joke from back in
season one with her talking about sucking him off
and the real bird person whispering the line
don't be gross tammy kind of crying a little bit
whole lot of blow jobs going around in this
episode between tammy and the garage ai
they chase him to the next memory which is after
the federation attacked his planet you notice
the building here in the background says historic
childhood trauma town as the federation captures
a bunch of bird persons people memory rick comes
back and jokes about not understanding the rules
of the episode am i invincible can we both die
in here are we damaging bird person's brain by
messing around with everything just calling out
the logic of the whole episode not totally making
sense then sort of flipping that on its head
by using his fake portal gun which doesn't work
as a shield they make fun of the shrek movies
younger rick saying he's just a grumpy ogre
and they made four of them and rick joking that
there's probably a fifth shrek movie in the time
that they've been doing this during the episode
morty is also a super fan of the shrek movies
they said of the whole idea of younger rick hating
the idea of older rick when he has to explain who
morty is and what his life is like how he's living
with the version of beth and like i said that's
also when they reveal that the beth that we've
been seeing this whole time has always been a
clone so if we're assuming that this season three
episode one memory of them actually did happen it
is a true memory he creates his first portal
gun and then at some point after this he gets
his revenge against the citadel that we see play
out in that earlier memory from the episode then
at some point after that he would have created
a clone version of beth and raised that version
and that's the version that we see during season
1 season 2 in season 3 up to the point where he
makes another clone and you get the space beth of
it all so it's almost like the writers are joking
like fans have been arguing who is the real beth
this whole time who's the clone is it space beth
is it the other bet that stayed home well joke's
on you because they both were clones this whole
time later rick makes another space beth reference
telling bird person at the end of the episode that
he shouldn't create a clone of his new kid and
then send it into space because apparently they
hate that then they travel to the next memory
which is inside the place where the federation
brought him back as phoenix person and mess with
his mind he tells the younger version of himself
to go look for secret intel on the federation they
don't really reference that again but because the
memory version of rick survives escaping into one
of rick's real memories he's just going to keep
on living in there real c137 rick now has access
to new intel on the federation that he acquired
he just needs to go back to the memory of his
childhood bedroom to find that version of rick
and ask him for that information all the bombs
that bird person is making to blow his own mind
metaphorically and literally are created
using energy from his negative emotions
like the negative aspects of his mind his rage
one of them is cringe one is denial blame fear
trauma depression disdain so it's a metaphor
for bird person metaphorically and literally
melting down like you talk about people in real
life having meltdowns having mental breakdowns
this is like a literal representation of that rick
makes a scientology joke claiming that he get in
a sauna with john travolta to save bird person
as younger rick tries to find them he starts
going around opening doors to different memories
this one is from their death at the wedding in
season two also allowing this version of tammy to
escape and chase them down later in the episode
both of the ricks then learn about the existence
of a bird person's child in another memory which
is also set up for that ending where bird person
calls him out for not telling him about the babies
sooner rick makes a blue man group when talking
about getting your mind blown because they're
metaphorically and literally blowing bird person's
mind during the episode then they traveled to bird
person's memory of their fight from the end of
season 4 when he was still phoenix person just
to steal the clothes off of this rick's back i
love the way this version of rick also reacts that
i always knew that this was the way i would die
we'll see if they pay that off during the final
rick and morty episode whatever the final season
winds up being then as the reality a bird person's
mind starts to crumble around them they take a
shortcut by traveling through bird persons ptsd
represented by the subway train which takes
them to the memory of the battle of blood ridge
the actual battle of blood ridge is an amazing
action set piece it must have taken them a long
time to animate this and the younger version of
rick is sort of a surrogate for the audience like
oh my god this is so cool i can't believe this the
giant walkers do kind of seem like star wars atats
and atsds but i actually think that they're meant
to be a different sci-fi movie reference so if you
think you know what these designs are based on
just write it below in the comments but the real
reason why it's such a major event in rick's life
isn't because it was a huge battle which it was
it's because it was sort of the moment of the end
of his friendship with bird person even though
it wasn't the actual end of their friendship they
basically broke up so to speak they made all these
references to them having this really bloody war
and them potentially losing the battle so the idea
was they didn't actually lose the battle against
the federation they beat the federation but rick
still feels like they lost the battle because he
lost the battle for his friend then they traveled
to the next memory which is a bird person in
tammy in the way the bird person explains it
he knew that he was getting ready to die like he
was about to die at any moment and wanted to die
with the person that he loved so he went to find
a version of tammy on a really nice day at their
house young rick makes a lincoln memorial joke
if you remember a couple episodes ago in the
thanksgiving episode the lincoln memorial in the
rick and morty multiverse is the secret entrance
to the us government's vault where they keep
the aliens who are basically responsible for
all technology and culture in the world rick calls
out all the tropes of the episode saying that the
closer the bird person's mind gets to collapsing
the more cannon bullcrap is going to come and try
and kill them which sets up tammy's joke revealing
that she is secretly a member of the federation
when rick says everybody knows that's just a
matter of reference to us the viewers having
learned about that a couple years ago rick tells
bird person about his child to get him to want to
live tammy then reveals what they would have done
with the child had there been one sort of setting
up the post-credit scene then they traveled
back to bird person's memory meeting tammy
for the first time at rick's party during season 1
when they teleported the house to another reality
making out on his workbench which apparently is
gross but rick doesn't think that squanchy jerking
off in his closet is gross because apparently
some closets are just for doing that meaning
rick has probably done that a lot in closets bird
person also apparently remembers the plumbus from
interdimensional cable them just wanting to bring
deep cuts easter eggs back from previous episodes
then they get attacked by other memory versions
of phoenix person and tammy who hates rick for
making her spend two years in high school just
for reference for people that don't live in the
united states high school for people in the us
is four years so she got off easy only having to
do two of those the gun converts memories into
energy which he also then can use the same way
that he uses his portal gun fluid using it to open
portals to other memories allowing them to escape
i'm also sure that they're going to be selling a
lot of this stuff in the episode that you see as
toys so like the guns the ships the vehicles
everything then they travel to the memory of gear
dude's funeral where we see young gearhead who
they run over and then when they're figuring out
where to travel next he mentions squanchy had a
very distasteful eulogy bird person suggests they
travel to squanchy's terrible stand-up phase
the bird flappers comedy club name is just a
reference to the flappers comedy club which is a
real comedy club in hollywood this version of rick
here getting pissed because he wasted his time
realizing that none of this was real when they
travel back to the original memory for the burning
man concert where they met for the first time we
see them forming their band flesh curtains for the
first time there was also a reference to the flesh
curtains band during episode 5 earlier this season
in the dive bar someone graffiti that their band
sucked and someone else crossing that out saying
that they really sucked there was also a squanchy
reference on the wall of that bar too young rick
sacrifices himself to save them from the tami from
the memory of their wedding later we find out he
somehow found a way to escape into real rick's
mind in the whole animation of the black ooze bird
monster here consuming the rest of the memories
actually feels kind of like a princess mononoke
reference deep cut it also kind of reminds me
of the pollution monster from fern gully for
anyone that saw that other old animated movie
they pulled that whole joke with bird person
speaking like rick and then revealing that it was
rick because bird person normally speaks in that
very formal way then he ports his mind back to his
body rick makes the same 100 years reference from
earlier in the series rick and bird person 100
years he makes the space beth reference again and
then bird person calls him out for withholding the
information about his child in they mutually part
ways like i said i think the whole vibe here is
that the writers are telling us that they're going
to bring bird person back eventually and they'll
pay off his child in a future episode like rick
will probably agree to help bird person rescue
his child and they'll just handle that in some
future season they pay off that joke about the
ai blowing gene and then they explain where the
younger rick went to hide inside rick's memories
he traveled into one of rick's earlier memories
from his own childhood so you see posters and
schematics for his spaceship you see a console
that he's modifying gears on his dresser just
generally references to all the adventures that he
will have someday as an adult the whole joke with
the babysitter is that she's getting super naked
in the living room and he just runs out to take a
peek so the joke here is that young rick traveled
back to hyde in a very fap-worthy fantasy moment
from his earlier childhood that's why he smiles
knowingly when little rick runs out to take a
peek at the babysitter all naked and then tries to
follow him too to also catch the naked babysitter
again older rick catching him in the act
knowing exactly what he was doing the whole time
i also love the joke where he offers to make him a
real person so that they can have a drink together
but the young rick still hates the idea of turning
into the old rick so much that he's like you know
what i'm gonna pass on that why don't i just stay
in here and you remember having a drink with me
also another huge reveal here so if you look at
the wall this is a big deal this is a picture
of rick's parents i think this is the first
time we've ever seen rick's parents depicted
on the series maybe we'll see some more
easter eggs for them in future seasons
then during the post-credits scene they pay
off bird person's child who looks kind of
like a little tammy with wings basically in bird
persons eyes being held captive in a federation
prison they get into a fight at super hardcore
and it actually feels like this is meant to be a
reference to star trek deep space nine there was
a season of that show where wharf and a couple
of the bigger side characters were trapped in a
secret dominion prison on a remote asteroid for
a long period of time and none of their friends
knew that they were there they had to escape
so like i said some future episodes they'll
probably pay this off having rick help
bird person rescue his child if you did spot
any easter eggs in the episode that i didn't
mention in the video just write them below in the
comments i have to say this is probably one of my
favorite episodes from the season so far like
i said the finale won't be till september 5th
but episode 9 will be a full hour long so it's
basically like two episodes jammed together
big reminder too this week marvel's what
if episodes are starting my full episode 1
video will post wednesday it'll be the exact same
schedule as my loki episode videos what if will
also be canon to the mcu the movies and the other
live action disney plus series i will try to do a
rick and morty finale trailer video i'll name a
giveaway winner when i post that video everyone
click here for my full suicide squad post credit
scene video and click here for my marvel what if
episode 1 trailer video and i'll replace the link
with my full episode 1 video after i post it later
this week thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!